welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and marvel's loki braces to
revolutionize our understanding of time
and the multiverse in the mcu and it
looks like rules and narrative
implications that might actually stick
this time
because unlike limited run series like
one division and the falcon the winter
soldier
marvel studios plans to continue loki's
story in a second season
so it's not just about getting the
character from a to b it's about
building out a whole new corner of the
world in the mcu
and yeah in order to justify such an
expansive future of episodes the world
building of this series is
everything and part of that world
building are these clues we're seeing in
the latest promo imagery centering
around these three mysterious figures
lurking behind loki in the shadows
these have shown up all over the time
variance authority headquarters and they
are called the time
keepers you were created by the
timekeepers correct
is that funny the idea that your little
club decides the fate of trillions of
people across all of existence at the
behest of three
space lizards yes it's funny now this
trio's history in the marvel comics is
super complicated but we're getting a
pretty good idea of how exactly they'll
play out in the disney plus series and
affect the broader mcu so
i'm gonna explain this madness spoiler
warning in case my theories are right
but if not it's fine because it's more
fun to be surprised so the time keepers
of the marvel comics are powerful
god-like beings who control
and oversee the flow of time their names
are actually asked
vort and xanth they reside in the
citadel at the end of all time where
all universes of the multiverse converge
at an endpoint they were created by
he who remains the final director of the
time variance authority hoping that they
would teach the next universal cycle to
help civilizations to
avoid the mistakes of the past of course
the timekeepers turn out to be giant
a-holes well actually at first their
creation makes them come out flawed
turning into the time twisters who go
backward in time destroying everything
in their path but that
ends up being in a separate reality from
the real time keepers
who will still kind of piss everyone off
the timekeepers buddy up with immortus
the time traveling villain later
revealed to be one of the identities of
kang the conqueror
and they send immortus after the
avengers and they send a mortise to
interfere with juan
maximos pregnancy when her offspring are
revealed to be linked to methule
i can't say his name because it triggers
people who think i'm an mcu
meteorologist but loki does have a
stained glass depiction of a red-faced
demon so just keep him in mind
because he always keeps you in mind
anyway the important thing to keep in
mind with the timekeepers is that they
are one
totally ridiculous two immoral frauds
and three
actually built by a lesser power and
those qualities appear to be what the
loki series is embracing
absurdly huge looming statues of the
timekeepers
all over tva headquarters in the wide
layout
propping up one of those platforms atlas
style also in the tva
archives in their courtroom and yes now
creeping up behind loki on the poster
but like many statues in real life do
these represent an
active living authority or do they
enshrine a past authority and values
from a previous era
loki understands this when he posed as
odin and asgard and thor ragnarok he set
up a statue in his own honor using the
belief that loki was dead
of course there was some [ __ ] which
is why i think loki now calls [ __ ]
here i'm gonna burn this place to the
ground
now it appears that the core plot of
this series is loki getting detained by
the tva
after his timeline breach and avengers
end game and forced by the tva to help
them hunt down a greater threat
which will likely be some alternate loki
variants
and or sophia dimartino's character
perhaps another loki variant lady loki
now you could kind of compare loki's
plot here to the wizard of oz
a traveler from another world brought to
a shining
emerald city ruled by a huge face
in order to kill a wicked witch but that
huge face is actually the illusion from
a con man with really nothing to offer
but before we continue do you ever cover
your eyes before opening your monthly
credit card balance because you're as
scared as a little kid
when a bad guy in a scary movie is
creeping up behind someone
well upstart can help you uncover those
eyes so that you can finally feel the
relief of being credit card debt free
upstart is the fast and easy way to get
a personal loan to pay off your debt all
online
over half a million people have used
upstart to get a simple fixed monthly
payment and with a five minute online
rate check you can see your rate up
front for loans from 1 000 to 50
000 loan amounts will be determined
based on your credit income and other
info provided on your loan application
you can get approved the same day and
can receive funds as fast as one
business day
don't let your credit card debt be the
michael myers dear jamie lee curtis find
out how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com
new rockstars that's upstart.com
newrockstars and don't forget to use our
url to let them know that we sent you
load amount to be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application again go to upstart.com
new rockstars so who would be the man
behind the curtain of
loki well richard e grant was announced
early on in this show but his role
remains
unknown and he has yet to appear in any
footage
richard e grant is known for playing
some nerd movie villains like
in the rise of skywalker and logan but
really his most celebrated role the one
he was nominated for an oscar for was
can you ever forgive me
as a weasley yet sympathetic fraudster
who helps melissa mccarthy's character
trick
literature collectors i think grant
could be playing
he who remains an older desperate but
proud
tva agent who created the timekeepers to
establish the tva's authority
as divine when in reality these
timekeepers don't really do
or mean anything and the authority of
the tva
really comes from the place it does for
all bureaucracies
never ending regulations in red tape
that way he who remains could be the
tba's master clockmaker
who set up this vast infrastructure of
the time variance authority
made up some [ __ ] about their
founders being this holy trinity of time
gods to make everyone fear and respect
the tva
and then steps back to let this tightly
wound clock tick
away on its own now notice how front and
center of that loki poster is a
character i was a bit surprised to see
featured so prominently
the animated mascot of the tva named
miss minutes
in a recent inside marvel i speculated
whether miss minute's appearance as a
function or destination on the tva
elevator could make her the tva's attack
dog or
torturer of misbehaving detainees
whatever her role is like with some
workplaces
she could just live on as this
annoyingly cute office motivator with
catchphrases like
doggy but functionally she plays the
same role as the timekeeper
an automated symbol designed just to
keep the clock
ticking but the reason loki and his
variants are such a threat
is that loki is a god or at least he
sees himself as one like he is the ego
of a god
and he knows all about setting up
[ __ ] shrines in his own honor
so this whole majesty and symbolism of
the tva does not work on him
and i'm assuming loki is perceptive and
skeptical enough
to assume that it wasn't he who
initially broke reality into a messy
multiverse the multiverse already exists
and in truth it could have been the
higher ups of the tva like director he
who remains
who initially meddled with the time
stream to serve his own ends
and cover up some corruption now as a
proud member of the kangang
i'm holding on to my reach theory that
what the tva tells us
are the all-powerful timekeepers were in
reality
an experiment gone awry that led to one
of these betraying the others and
becoming
kang slash immortus who by the way will
be played by jonathan majors in ant-man
and the wasp quantum mania he's coming
to the mcu and he might show up in this
show like justice rensselaer is going to
be in it that's kang's love interest and
there's other clues i've talked about
before
kang could be the tva skeleton in the
closet their dark dirty secret that they
screwed with the time stream to cover up
and now they're blaming it all on loki
but really i think it's likely that this
loki series begins by
setting up the other loki variants and
dimartino's character as the apparent
villains
but as the episodes go on loki joins
forces with those variants to turn on
the real threat the fraud behind the
curtain of the tva
that way they can oust that corrupt
leader but still keep the tva running
under the directorship of renslayer
because to be honest
i don't want the tva to collapse like
shield did we need a cruel bureaucracy
in this universe to keep us honest and
in this case
keep us on time hey a reminder that our
inside marvel loki after shows will move
to wednesday
starting june 9th with our episode
easter egg breakdowns releasing as soon
as possible afterward probably thursdays
just so we can keep up with new loki
episodes coming out on wednesdays so be
sure to subscribe to new rockstars for
the most
overthought analysis of this series also
support this channel by checking out
some great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com we got a new loki
shirt in the works i think you're gonna
love it
follow me on instagram and twitter at ea
boss follow new rockstars thank you for
watching bye
[Music]
you